okay there are three tasks in doing
something first you decide what it is
you're going to do second you decide how
to do it and third you do it now there
are three tasks and programming first
you decide what the program should do
then you decide how the program should
do it and you implement these decisions
in code coding obviously important part
of that but I have very little to say
about it I'm going to be talking about
the other two parts of the the other two
tasks and every programmer performs
these tasks before coding no one starts
coding and then decides later on whether
she's actually writing a database or web
browser just some idea before starting
you know what she's going to do and no
one just starts writing code and hopes
that it happens to turn into a web
browser you think about how the program
should do it so these are the tasks that
I'm talking about it's the thinking we
do before we code and we need to do this
thinking so how should we do it well how
hard should we think well that depends
on how hard the problem is for a really
hard problem for example the problem of
building a fault-tolerant distributed
system we'd better do a lot of really
hard thinking for a really easy problem
by implement an integer variable by one
well that's trivial no thinking is
required really nothing to think about
what about overflow
this is not working
nope
so you have to do some thinking in order
to know how easy a problem really is now
thinking can prevent errors well have to
say clear thinking can prevent errors
fuzzy thinking can't and wishful
thinking can in fact lead to errors so
how do we think clearly we right my
favorite quotes writing is nature's way
of letting you know how sloppy your
thinking is and if you're thinking
without writing you only think you're
thinking
so specifications specifications are
what we write when we're thinking about
performing tasks 1 & 2 they can serve
multiple purposes especially in large
project but I'm going to concentrate on
one purpose helping us to think clearly
clear thinking is important and it's
hard we need all the help that we can
get so we know write specifications what
language would use should we use to
write them that's the first question
computer scientists ask you want to do
anything what language should we use
well there's no single answer
programming problems are too diverse
sometimes we want to use TLA plus the
specification language that I've
designed sometimes we won't want to use
Mandarin it all depends on the
circumstances but there's a lot better
is a much better question to ask how can
we think more clearly
and the answer is by thinking like a
scientist it's a way of clear thinking
that has worked quite well for the last
500 or so years so how does science work
science makes mathematical models of
reality
for example astronomy perhaps arguably
the first science the reality is that
you know planets are complicated things
they have mountains oceans tides all
sorts of stuff and the model that's been
used for centuries in astronomy is that
a planet is a point mass that just has
position and momentum so models versus
reality a model is useful for certain
purposes the model of the planet is a
point mass with position and momentum
that's been quite useful when the
problem you want to solve is you know
where should I point my telescope in
order to see that planet it's not good
for predicting the planets weather so
math is what allows us to deduce
properties of the model science is what
tells us what those properties say about
reality okay so I'm here to talk about
computer science
this being the gates building and the
reality that we're dealing with are
digital systems they come in many
flavors processor chip a game console a
computer executing a program and and so
on I'm going to be talking about you
know computers executing a program but
what I say applies to any digital system
what models do we use for this reality
model this reality oh there are lots of
ones we've you know computer scientists
use they're touring machines partially
ordered sets of events
you know probably hundreds I don't know
well what's a program well by a program
I mean any piece of code it makes sense
to think about by itself so when I talk
about programs so a programming tasks
like build a web browser it's a program
the web browser we design the users view
will write a high level design and part
three we write the code well in writing
code we come across other programming
tasks for example we better to build a
text for matter as part of the web
browser well there are three tasks to
building the text formatter decide what
it's supposed to do decide what
algorithm you're going to use to format
and write the code and you may discover
there's a programming some tasks there
you have to hyphenate words to do the
text formatting so once again there are
the three tasks that must be performed
so programming the task these this three
tasks process happens at many many
levels in implementing a program so task
1 specifying what the program does
the most common mathematical model that
is functions we model a program as a
function that map's inputs to outputs
and in mathematics a function is usually
described as simply the set of ordered
pairs for example the square function on
natural numbers it's represented by this
set of ordered pairs for example this
ordered pair two fours we usually just
the fact that that is an element of the
of the function we usually write as
saying that's square of two equals four
the domain of the of this function is
the set of
first elements in this case it's what I
write is not the set of natural numbers
and to define a function we specify its
domain and what for each element exits
domain we write a mathematical formula
describing what square of X is equal to
now I should warn you functions and math
are not the same as functions in
programming languages math ISM is an
awful lot simpler than programming
languages so when I talk about a
function I'm talking about mathematical
function so the example I'll use is a
very trivial one because I don't have
time to explain anything non-trivial
so use a GCD program the programming
tasks write a see function or drama
method to compute the GCD of two
integers so the spec of what the program
should do it computes the GCD of M&N for
inputs M&N where GCD is the function
whose domain is the set of but yeah it's
a set of pairs of integers and the GCD
of something in the domain is the
largest integer that divides both of
them okay reality versus the model
reality a number is a 32-bit C or Java
end the model a number is a mathematical
integer this model is going to allow us
to reason about the correctness of the
basic GCD algorithm it's not going to
catch overflow errors that would require
a more complicated model and since I
have no time only for a really simple
example I'm not going to discuss
overflow okay limitations of the
function model well some programs don't
just map inputs to out
it's they may run forever for example an
operating system that's usually not good
so a function model isn't isn't good for
task to describing how something you
know how something operates it may be
fine even for programs that just
computer function and may be fine for
saying what the function does but not
for how it does it for example quick
sort and bubble sort compute the same
function but they're very different
algorithms so to describe how something
does it for task two I use what I call
the standard behavioral model where a
program execution is represented by a
behavior a behavior is a sequence of
states and the state is an assignment of
values to variables and a program is
modeled as a set of behaviors the set of
behaviors that represent all possible
legal executions so let's true task to
for Euclid's algorithm we say we want to
compute GCD by Miss initializing x2m and
wide n using two variables x and y we
keep track subtracting the smaller from
the larger and we stop when they're
equal at which point they both equal the
GCD that we're trying to compute so for
M equals 12 and N equals 18 you can see
there's this one possible behavior it's
a different button no it says it's like
well at any rate you can see there are
three states you started this initial
state x equals twelve y equals 18 we
subtract the smaller from the larger
thank you
then we we get this state that we
subtract the love smaller from the
larger we get this state and they're
equal so we stop okay let's see if maybe
this this part of the device works too
Oh down okay okay so here's our
specification the two tasks that's what
it's supposed to do and how it does it
okay well what if M equals 12 and N
equals minus 18 well specification the
largest integer that divides both of
them is 6 but what if we do these series
of steps I think you know we subtract
the smaller width and bigger we subtract
8 minus 18 from 12 and oh I'm not sure
maybe it does stop well actually then we
get 30 maybe it would stop sorry
never realize that actually does seem to
work anyway what if m and n are equal to
0 0 and minus 18 okay thank you
not having tried to write a proof for
when they're integers I've never yeah
actually that's right zero and eighteen
wouldn't work either okay so every
number divides zero so there is no
largest one so the GCD is not defined so
what are we going to do well when you
situation like that we go back to task
one and we say do we really need to
compute the GCD of non positive in
numbers and for simplicity I'm going to
assume we don't you just you know
positive integers are fine then there's
a simple fix we just we just changed the
specification an aside productivity
I wrote end lines of code today for your
favorite value but I was really
productive well much greater
productivity is I eliminated n lines of
code today those are n lines of code
that are not going to have any any bugs
that saves them that's a lot more
productive the easiest place to
eliminate code is in task one we think
really hard about what we really need do
we need all those bells and whistles the
best way to simplify your program and to
save time is to not do things that you
don't have to do so you think really
hard about tasks to test one the second
easiest place to eliminate code is in
task two now thinking will make you less
productive if productivity is measured
in lines of code written because if you
think really hard about task two you'll
find an easier way to do it you know
it's going to produce fewer lines of
code now this toy example isn't going to
convince you you know I don't know how
to count all the lines of code I haven't
written because I wrote specs because I
thought really
hard about task 1 and task 2 and if
somebody does a controlled experiment
you're not even allowed to do task 1 you
don't allowed to change what the program
does
ok that's the end of my aside now it's
easy to miss problems in informal
specifications now specifying functions
Rick rigorously is really
straightforward it's just ordinary a
very simple math you just write your
function what it does very precisely
what I'm going to talk about is
rigorously specifying the standard
behavioral models so how do we describe
a set of behaviors well there's a
theorem that says that any set of
behaviors can be described by a safety
property in the liveness property and
intuitively a safety properly asserts
that something bad doesn't happen it
really is this
for instance the program doesn't produce
a wrong answer liveness property asserts
that something good eventually happens
for example that it eventually produces
an answer in practice specifying safety
is usually more important that's usually
where wor errors come and to save time
I'm going to ignore liveness in this
talk not that it's not important not
that you know we can't reach do it
handle it very rigorously I just don't
have time to to talk about it
so how do you specify safety properties
you specify two things the set of
initial States and next state relation
describing all possible successor States
of any state so how do we specify them
we act like scientists we use math so
the set of initial States it's described
by a formula for example for Euclid's
algorithm the formula says that x equals
m and y equals m there's only one state
at least for any particular value of M
and M so it's the only possible initial
state the next state relation
we describe it by a formula and in this
formula we use unprimed variables to
talk about the current state prime
variables for the next state in other
words we will form our next state
relation it's a relation on pairs of
states and the first state I call the
current state and the second state we
call the next state so for Euclid's
algorithm well it's the disjunction of
two formulas two cases one where X is
greater than Y the other one Y is
greater than X in the first case the new
value of x we get by we do is we
subtract the smaller and for the larger
so the new value of x is equal to the
old value of X minus the old value of y
and the new value of y is equal to its
old value we don't change it and
similarly this is the second case
so for Euclid's algorithm you know how
does this work well again the same
example M equals 12 and equals 18 the
initial predicate as we've seen uniquely
determines in this case a single initial
state to find the next state where we
substitute the values of the current
state for for the variables and then we
find what possible values of x prime and
y prime what possible values in the new
States there are well twelve greater
than eighteen is false 18 greater than
twelve is true false and anything is
false and true in anything is equal to
that thing so we see that the one
possible solution is y pride the new
value of y is 18 minus 12 and the new
value of x is 12 so that's the unique
possible next state find the next state
do the same thing it's up to through 12
for X and 6 for Y and you can see in
that case it's the top conjunction it's
the only one that's a disjunction that's
the only one that can be true and the
unique solution to that says that X
prime is 12 minus 6 and y prime equals
six so that's the next state and we try
to find the state after that and we find
that six greater than six is false
so both disjuncts are false so this
formula equals false which means there
is no next state so the algorithm halls
so this is the complete task to
specification simple ordinary math like
scientists and engineers use you know
I'm not talking some weird computer
science mess now we can actually combine
these two formulas into a single
temporal logic formula that I write this
way but it's actually elegant that it's
not hard to understand I don't have time
to explain it and you only need to talk
about look at this formula for liveness
you don't need it for safety and since
I'm going to be talking about safety I'm
gonna ignore that temporal logic stuff
yeah temporal I don't like temporal
logic it's not ordinary math you know
for very very you know precise
mathematical reasons so but so you want
to stay away from it as much as possible
it happens to be a necessary evil when
you want to reason very rigorously about
liveness but you don't have to worry
about it for safety so and that's what
I'm going to be talking about okay
nucleus algorithm for any particular x
and y there's a unique values of x prime
and y prime that make the next state
relation true in other words you plaits
algorithm is deterministic to model non
determinism nothing special is needed we
just write a next state relation that
allows multiple next states for a
current state and multiple assignments
of values to prime variables that make
next true for a single assignment of
values ton prime variables it's it's not
rocket science that's very easy to do
I'm just not going to
give any example it involves
non-determinism well what about formal
specs I mean there's mathematics and
there's formalism and there's formal
mathematics you need formal mathematics
if you want to build an actual tool you
know and make sure it's doing the right
thing then you need something that's
completely formal and so to do things
formulae we need a formal language and
the language that I use is called TL A+
this is this that Euclid's algorithm
spec in ela plus becomes this I have
this funny symbol for writing is defined
to be equal to specification is just a
definition in this case two definitions
for these two parts of the specification
me add some declarations a little
boilerplate and that's the TLA plus spec
for Euclid's algorithm and this is what
it looks like in SK well you see this is
you know not terribly difficult and you
can actually model check TLA plus spec
like this model checking is basically
exhaustive execution that is all
examining all possible behaviors on a
small model in this case our small model
would be just particular values for M
and n now model checking is extremely
effective and you know pretty easy it's
mostly just push the button and let the
model check or do the work you can also
write formal correctness proofs and
check them mechanically but that's hard
work and very few programmers we were
ever going to do that so a problem with
CLA plus is that it's math programmers
and computer scientists are afraid of
math I wish I were joking but I mean
I've had a colleague just you know tell
me you know how he was trying to explain
the TLA Plus spec to some developers and
he said when the form
went onto the board you know their eyes
glazed over
you know unfamiliarity turns people off
my solution is plus Cal it looks like a
toy programming language the algorithm
actually appears in a comment in a TL A+
module and an expression of the plus Cal
can be any TL a plus expression which
really means it's anything you can write
in in mathematics it also has constructs
for non-determinism but the ability to
write any TLA plus expression makes it
enormous ly X you know makes an enormous
ly expressive language much more
expressive than anything any programmer
language any programming language
designer would ever dream of and it gets
compiled to an easy-to-understand TL A+
spec that is the correspondence between
the tli plus and the plus pal is easy to
see if you write a really complex bus
Cal spec it's not going to miraculously
become simple in the TLA plus but it
snows no more complicated than the plus
Cal itself and you can apply TL a plus
tools to to check it and it helps people
overcome their math phobia and it's
fairly it's easy for even programmers
and computer scientists to understand
and I've actually I don't publish
algorithms anymore but the ones I've
published in the last 10 years or so
have been in plus cow and computer
scientists live with it but of course TL
a plus and plus Carol or math and we all
know that math works only for toy
examples you know model real systems you
need a real language with types
procedures objects all of that stuff mad
wrong a report what Chris Newcomb was a
namet who was an Amazon engineer said
about their use of TL A+ at Amazon I'll
flash it on when I when your lips stop
moving I'll go on
in every case TLA plus has added
significant value either preventing Siri
subtle serious bugs from reaching
production or giving us enough
understanding and confidence to make
aggressive performance optimizations
without correctness one of the reasons
you hear about why formal methods are no
good because they produce inefficient
code
well they do exactly the opposite and
another thing people will tell you that
oh well the engineers may like them but
managers are never going to let them do
it
managers are encouraging teams to write
TLA Plus specs and they allocate
engineering time you know the other
thing is oh well we'd like to do it but
they don't give us enough time if n
managers see that it works they they do
it this was written you know six months
ago or so Chris has since left Amazon
the latest number I heard is that
they're now 14 large systems that
they've used it on and more groups are
learning it as we speak
as I speak another example the Xbox 360
memory system Chuck Thacker had a summer
intern come and write a TLA + spec of
the memory system of the Xbox 360 just
writing the spec caught a bug that would
not otherwise have been found the IBM
engineers who built the chip said yes
indeed our tests would not have caught
that bug and that bug would have caused
every xbox360
to crash after four hours of continual
use now you can learn about TLA plus on
the web today i'm not going to be
talking about formal specs i'm going to
be talking about informal specs formal
specs is another talk so I'll use this
an example you know we don't write
programs too
most of the time to compute you know G
CDs and stuff like that
a more typical you know type of
programming problem that we encounter
might be writing a pretty printer for
some language so I wrote a pretty
printer for T la parte la plus now the
input for the pretty printers at e la
specification might have a formula like
this and if we did the naive output of
something you know cows pay you know a
lot of certain amount of distance for a
particular space and you know then just
put the letters in you'd get something
like like that but the user probably
wanted you know if you wrote things this
way he probably wanted these things to
be aligned so what he really wanted the
right output would look something like
like this on the other hand suppose the
input looked like this
the naive amplitude be that but in this
case those alignments were probably just
happen by chance and so in that case the
naive output is actually the right
output so there is no precise
mathematical definition of correct
output because it means what the user
wants and we can't mathematically
specify what the user wants so if we can
specify correctness specification is
useless right of course not not knowing
what a program should do doesn't mean we
don't have to think about it it means we
have to think a lot harder and writing a
spec means we have to write it and
thinking hard means you know really
thinking about writing a spec so the
spec becomes even more important so it's
impossible to specify the best pretty
printer
but the program has to do something and
just saying oh we're not going to
specify it and sit down and write
stream-of-consciousness code is not a
way of producing a good program so what
am i spec look like my spec consisted of
six rules plus definitions and these
were written in comments in the Java
file and here's an example of one of the
rules a left comment token is left
comment aligned with its covering token
well left comment aligned is a defined
term as is covering token and it has
left comment token if you look at this
spec it's what I call mathematical
English it's the way mathematicians
would describe mathematics you know you
make some definitions and then you write
some rules in terms of those definitions
so why did I write the spec well because
it was a lot easier to understand and
debug six rules then the conjugated 850
lines of code that those rules produced
now wasn't easy to write those those
rules I had to you know spend a lot of
time debugging them and in fact I wrote
debugging code that reported what the
rules were would do so I coded up the
rules and you know tried them out and a
bunch of examples and when they didn't
work I didn't have to debug you know 850
lines of code I was debugging six rules
and the few bugs that that happened in
implementing them that were easy to
catch you know Java tools are you know
really quite good at doing that
you know caching that sort of thing had
I just written code it would have taken
me much longer and would have not have
produced formatting as good so why not a
formal spec well for one thing getting
it right wasn't that important you know
if it pretty printer just screws up on
some thing well you know it's going to
screw up on some things anyway because
you know what somebody screw up is
somebody else's correct output so
and so yeah it didn't have to work in
all the corner cases and possibly even
more important is there weren't any
tools that could help me the TLA plus
Mont you know model checkers you know
would just have been useless in that
situation because you know how can I
create a model for it you know it'd have
to anything mathematically I would have
to hand code the you know examples in
mathematics and it just wouldn't have
been feasible
okay so what's typical about this spec
what's typical is that the spec is at a
higher level than the code it could have
been implemented in any language no
method or tool for writing better code
would have helped me to write the spec
now nothing you're gonna learn in a
coding class or a programming language
course you know it's going to help you
write a spec like that and no method or
tool but no Magnificent programming
language would have made that spec
unnecessary you know unless you were
writing a programming language for
particularly for a writing you know TL
A+ pretty printers and the spec says
nothing about how to actually write the
code it says what the code should do not
how it should do it you write a spec to
help you think about the problem before
you think about the code so what's not
typical about this spec is first that's
quite subtle at least 95 percent of the
code that we write you know task 1 and
task 2 the specs are shorter you know
and you know very many a much simpler
specs will suffice the second thing
that's not typical is that it's a set of
rules a set of rules or requirements or
axioms is usually a terrible spec
because it's hard to understand the
consequences of a set of rules and a
matter of fact that's why
and had to spend a long time debugging
these rules but for this particular
problem you know it happened to be the
best way I knew of specifying it okay
programs that run forever I've been
talking about programs the computer
function programs that run forever
usually involve concurrency you know
operating systems distributed systems
few people can get them right by just
thinking and just writing you know I'm
not one of them maybe once upon a time I
was we need tools to check what we do
and if you have to do that use TLA plus
or Pascal or find something you know
that's as good but if you're in the
process of designing concurrent
algorithms neat you're gonna need tools
to check them to make sure you get them
right the other 95% well here's a
typical example you couldn't even read
this this specification of what the code
did is supposed to do you know pretty
trivial why did I bother writing that
spec well to be sure I knew what the
code should do before writing it without
writing a spec I only thought I knew
what the code should do and later I
didn't have to read the code to know
what it did so you know my one general
might maybe I have a second general what
first general rule is that there are no
general rules and like any rule that has
an exception the exception to that is
there is this general rule that I have
which a spec of what the code does
should say everything that anyone needs
to know to use the code now in this case
how the code you know the particular
simple example how the code work was too
simple to require a spec so what
programmers should know about thinking
well first what everybody should know
about thinking everybody thinks they
think
but if you wrote don't write down your
thoughts you're fooling yourself what
programmers should eat you should know
about thinking you should think before
you code which means you should write
before you code and the spec is nothing
magic nothing terribly complicated
nothing forbidding it's simply what you
write before coating so what code should
you specify any piece of code that
somebody else might want to use or
modify and that means you know you may
be that user next month it could be the
entire program or system certainly
you're writing a big program you needle
through a lot of thinking which not only
means you gonna do a lot of writing
might be a you know a Java class a
method they sometimes you know even a
tricky piece of code in the method if is
something that's tricky or anyway in the
middle of method I'll write comment you
know inside that says here's what the
following piece of code is doing so what
should you specify the path the code
what it does which means everyone any
everything anyone needs to know to use
it and possibly how it does it that's
not a very trivial and we called that
how it does it if something it's if
there's how it does it is if it's
problem that you know we learn about in
our algorithms course then we call it an
algorithm if it's not if something more
special purpose that you're just the
first person who's ever done something
like that then we call it a high-level
design but you know there's no formal
difference between the two high-level
design an algorithm or high-level design
is an abstraction an abstract model of a
program so how should you think about
and specify the code above the code
level that's the most important thing
in terms of states and behaviors if
you're writing a statement you know
specification of how it works and
mathematically as rigorously as formally
as necessary
perhaps with pseudocode or plus calif c
specifying how how do you learn to write
specs by writing formal specs they
writing formal specs will help will
teach you the skills you need in order
to thinking skills you need in order to
be able to know how to write specs
informally when that's the appropriate
thing to do how do you learn to write
formal specs well you learn to write
programs by writing them running them
and correcting errors you can learn to
write formal specs by writing them
running them that is checking them with
a model checker and correcting your
errors now tl a+ may not be the best
language for your sports formal
specification needs i mean there are
lots of different things that one needs
to do there are lots of formal languages
you know they're all good for something
the pla plus and you know is quite
likely not going to be the best formal
tool for your particular i need but i
think it's a great tool for learning to
think mathematically so how do you
connect the spec to the code
well you'll write comments that connect
the mathematical concepts and their
implementation for example if your if
your algorithm is in terms of graphs you
know you'd write implementing a graph
algorithm something that's manipulating
that at the Montand your model of it is
this is an implementing graphs well the
actual program is ER is implementing
arrays and nodes and bits and all of
that stuff and so what you simply do is
write down
is the precisely these this the graph
you know a graph is a set of nodes and a
set of if it's a directed graph a set of
ordered pairs of nodes and you explain
you know how the graph is is being
modeled being implemented in terms of
these programming language structures
what about coding nothing I've said
implies anything about writing the code
itself you still have to think while you
while you code and if coding a subtask
is difficult or subtle specify at first
then write the code but I have nothing
to say about the coding itself use any
programming language you want use any
methodology you want I'm not going to
you know try to distinguish you know
snake oil from useful stuff I'm I don't
even have the expertise to do it you're
still going to have to test and debug
because remember or even if no matter
how carefully you verify even if you've
written a correct profile formal proof
your there's your abstract model there
could still be bugs in the
implementation you can write an
incorrect implementation of a correct
model now writing specs is an additional
step it may save time by catching errors
early when they're easier to correct
people at Amazon say that that it does
that for them it will improve your
programming so you write better programs
so why are programmers reluctant to
write specs writing is hard and why it's
writing hard because writing requires
thinking and thinking is hard is this
vicious circle it's easier to think
you're thinking writing is a lot like
running the less you do it the slower
you are and you know you have to
strengthen your writing muscles you know
judge there's a runner has to strengthen
her leg muscles
it takes practice you know device I can
give is right right right and a lot
easier to find excuses not to so what if
the spec is wrong maybe you made a
mistake
maybe the requirements change or some
enhancement is needed actually the code
may have to be changed you may be even
before the program is finished but you
know having to change the program you
know happens vet you eventually happens
to all useful programs believe me if
your program is really useful somebody's
going to want it to do something
something else or someone gonna tell you
how to fix it how to make it better so
eventually you know the spec is no
longer you know we haven't there's no
longer right now in an ideal world all
you have a new problem well I do is
write a new spec and then completely
recode it well we know how often that's
likely to happen in the real world the
code is going to be patched and maybe
the spec is updated so if this is
inevitable why bother writing specs
reason one who ever has to modify the
code will be eternally grateful for
every word or every formula of spec that
you write and believe me you know I
often have to modify my code that I
write you know and I will sometimes kick
myself for not having specified it well
enough and believe me I write more
specification than code and remember you
know that whoever might be you that's
why you should always update the spec
when you change the code reason too
every time you could patch code it
becomes a little uglier harder to
understand and harder to maintain you
know scientists have a law about that is
called entropy but if you don't start
with a spec
every single piece of code you write
it's a patch and so the problem starts
out being ugly hard to understand and
hard to maintain no battle was ever won
according to plan but no battle was
everyone without one quote by somebody
who knew something about winning battles
so some people will tell you that
writing specs is a waste of time and in
some sation some situations you maybe it
is maybe sometimes something is so
simple that there's no need to think
about what you're doing but remember
when they're telling you not to write a
spec what they're really telling you to
do is not to think so you should think
about whether you really don't have to
think about something thinking doesn't
guarantee that you won't that you won't
make mistakes there are no bandage magic
bullets you know programming it's
difficult we're you know we write
building complex things and it's hard to
get them right so there's no manual
thinking isn't gonna guarantee that you
won't make mistakes but not thinking
guarantees that you will to find out
more about TLA plus and plus code you
can just go to my home my TLA webpage or
go to my home page and there's a link to
it ok thank you
got there are five questions here
yes I think this is an extraordinarily
timely talk
what you told the young folks today and
I'm gonna be all folks is is
tremendously pity and important however
I would point out that in multix in 1965
we never let a person write a line of
code without a an informal specification
that was pretty detailed now in the
seventh in the city in the seventies we
did this thing that's right where there
was a formal spec for every function in
the hardware and the software all the
way up it was an onyx acute Abul
specification today we finally get
around to executable specifications for
hardware and software in nirav debase
thesis for example where he's able to
compile either into this back into
hardware into barrel lug or into C or
C++ or whatever you like so I think the
idea of a an executable specification in
some sense gets rid of your test three
altogether and it's something that was
fantasy back in the 60s and 70s but
suddenly is becoming reasonable today
well I think it's wonderful if you can
compile inspect
executable code from your specification
and as a matter of fact there are people
that MSR are well not executable code
directly from the specification well ok
forget I said that's irrelevant
I believe that it is possible to code
directly from something even from a TL
A+ spec written in a constrained Star
that is that can be complain for a
particular problem domain that can be
compiled into executable sufficiently
efficient code and I you know encourage
people to do it that's that's not
something you know I work on but I think
that it's important to avoid the trap of
you know your the right as you know code
from a specification language well we
need to get you know a little more
efficient code so we need to constrain
the specification language in this way
and we have been constrained in that way
and suddenly you don't have a
specification any language anymore you
have a programming language and you know
I believe that in the foreseeable future
we're still going to need programming
languages and we're still going to need
you know higher level abstraction
backtrack models of them it doesn't seem
that you need only two levels that can
program you can have specs and specs and
so on and and different levels of to
stop it but I want you to comment on it
on a couple of things one is that you
know I've seen a lot of cases where you
have these three tasks you know in the
cloud so I wanted to know how to do it
so so therefore you hire three groups of
people and put them in three different
buildings
somebody's a specialist in in one and
something special to it something three
I'd like you to comment on that
hierarchal specifications I think I
think that actually I think they're a
bit oversold but they are fine
especially for pedagogical purposes at
ela plus you know you can you can in ela
and TL A+ in CLA the underlying logic
implementation is mathematical
implication so to prove you know say
that one specification implements
another really means that the formula
that describes that is that
specification implies the formula
describes the high-level specification
so you note ela ela + were pacifically
design very much designed to deal with
hierarchical specifications this
question about you know different groups
of different specializations well it
seems to be a you know mr. inevitable
fact of life the people who people that
Intel you know this there's some people
at Intel who you know design their chips
and TL A+ and they give them to the
people you know who do the next level
the register transfer level and there
are different levels areas of expertise
and you know down there's a level below
that where you know you have to
understand you know some things about
electricity you know which the people of
the highest level you know they can plug
in a plug into a computer and that's
probably all they know about electricity
so the thing about writing and writing
precisely is that well if you do split
it into layers like that then you have
to be really sure that what you're
writing is clear and precise to make
sure that there that's really understood
by other people
from yo I'm not good at working in a
group so I can't see like the right a
good specialist I also understood
something my electricity it's not so
much their way thirdly I told
everything's act cool but but Whitehead
said one of my favorite quotes and I'll
probably get it wrong about something
because the purpose of mathematics is to
avoid thinking still I think it's
compatible with what you were saying
because he meant once you've got
something specified in mathematics then
you don't have to keep reasoning about
what what it is you can just assume
mechanically you know solve the
equations or stuff like that
yeah I would say that what Whitehead
meant is that mathematics lets you avoid
thinking about those things that don't
require thinking tell people is you know
mathematics is what you write to explain
something when you understand it the
mathematics itself sometimes you know by
clarifying your thoughts and mathematics
can give you way better ways to think
that you know you know that will help us
but your ultimate ly in making a
mathematical model you have to
understand you know what you're modeling
and Don's comment about you know you
know he would you know want to know a
little something about electricity
you know before specifying you know a
chip and you know that's that's very
pertinent because it's what makes
computer science or any science
different from mathematics you have to
you know when you write an algorithm
it's not
mathematics you have to understand what
computers can do and what they can't do
in order to know whether your algorithm
is reasonable or not so again you know
the it nothing that I'm saying you know
you know the mathematics isn't going to
free you from that basic knowledge of
computer science but it helps you
express that that knowledge John in the
agile development style the philosophy
if you can't possibly understand your
system in advance of building big chunks
of it and so by definition you have to
write a lot of code before your
understanding or purchase anywhere near
completeness how how does specification
fit into that world is a kind of victory
without approaches well there are two
situations first of all the question is
you may often have to write write code
to unbe cuz I'm using building you know
writing code using a system that is
unspecified and so I have to write code
just to understand you know what the
interface that is providing me does and
I throw that code away and so there's no
need to specify that code now if you're
trying to have to build something that
you know you can't understand it until
you know can't know what it's supposed
to do until you you actually implement
it you've got a tough problem you know
as I said I don't have any magic bullet
but remember if you're writing code that
somebody is going to have to modify
later
you know that's specific writing a
specification of the code is going to
help a lot and also again you're not
just writing random you know random code
you have some idea that you want to test
and so it's a lot better to think hard
about that basic idea before you put it
into code and maybe you can even find
some way of writing you know if you're
lucky or smart
maybe you could actually write an
executable model than you could actually
you know debug or simulate or something
to find out if your idea is going to
work you know that's something you know
we'd you know I think everybody would
like to do instead of actually building
the system but you know we may not know
how to do it so we do the best we can
but you know it's still even if you even
if you don't know what this you know
exactly you know whether this thing is
going to work you'd like to know for
example that it doesn't work not because
you know because your basic ideas were
we're wrong rather than you made some
coding error because you know you just
coded it really sloppily I've been
pressed by the impedance mismatch
between five lines of spec and 500 lines
of programming language now there were
some programming languages that try to
represent mathematics like APL for
example and you could express the law in
the one line of APL as you can in many
other very difficult to read programming
languages like Perl
but you considered using do you ever try
to use something like APL as a
specification language I've never felt
the need for anything else because you
know I used and you know mathematics
you know just seems the natural way if I
want to say something precisely I mean
you know it's been developed over a
couple of thousand years to say things
precisely I don't want to and you know
short doesn't necessarily mean simple as
you you've said so I don't know you can
look at my Euclid algorithm
specification and I think that is the
simplest specification that you know
I've ever you know I would know how to
write
you certainly write something you know
more compact in a programming language
but all you're doing is you're hiding
complexity in the language constructs
and you know what I started decided
specification language I thought that I
was going to need a lot of the stuff
that programming languages use use you
know objects or stuff like that but I
didn't know what they were and so I
decided I would start just with
mathematics and I was somewhat surprised
to realize that I didn't need anything
other than mathematics I sometimes had
to develop some notations for things
that mathematicians don't you that that
are common in in main modeling computer
systems that mathematicians haven't
developed notation for there are a
couple of things that I've done that are
learned from programming languages which
have to do with dealing with large
things because no specification that the
Amazon people write I don't know maybe a
thousand lines of formulas you know
mathematicians don't write formulas a
thousand lines long
but the sorts of things that I used for
example you noticed variable
declarations you know it turns out those
are good things because you know they
help catch errors if you you know
misspelled a variable you know stuff
like that you know this is a module
structure that I've given which is not
used actually much by engineers but but
basically I discovered that you know I
didn't need more than math anything with
the benefit but in mathematics agile is
that people are in the loop and when you
develop a program you learn something
from it
so that's where some of this practice of
agile
it's not perfectly joule defined five
lines of mathematics kind of problem
that you would solve you know they
weren't easy to write you know and I had
to debug them there was a cycle where so
you know I'm not saying that oh you
write your specification than you and
then you're done you know it's not a
magic bullet something missing it was
about this after after yep you're done
you just give nothing to it but you
don't explain why though it's actually
not good sometimes you have to show not
only what works but what does it doesn't
work you have to say something about the
subtle few something that's a good point
and in fact if you look at my code
you'll very often see things like you
know I tried this but it didn't work for
this reason for very simple reason you
know that you know I'm gonna come back
and want to do you know do something and
I'll look and say well if this looks so
simple why didn't I do it this way
because if I don't have numbers like
that in there somebody else could look
at and say well why didn't he do it this
simple way well everybody has a chick
has a right to change my programs if
they're yeah that's a good thing I mean
I must say I regard it as a second order
problem when his words typical as you
look at second you know open source
programming and you don't see any
comments about what it's doing in the
first place and the only way you can
tell what is doing is by no reading the
code and you know I can tell you you
know having spent you know a couple of
days with a debugger trying to figure
out what an interface did you know when
you know it
have taken me five minutes of reading a
short spec to to do it so yeah it's a
good point and when people saw you know
when everybody is writing specifications
I think there'll be another you know the
next crusade so I think we should let
the department chair ask the last
question and then we can adjourn if you
want to hang around with that we can
chat informally okay okay so I just want
to come back to Jon's question I think
I'll try to be succinct
so if you looking at its operated
economic proposition you could say that
you don't really need specs when you
have zero users I mean you don't care
whether the program works because you
have nobody running it and you know why
invest in the specifications and I think
a lot of startups work that way and I do
see though that once the code has
economic value people want to come back
and add specifications when you have big
companies and they they know the codes
thing ahead you can undervalue then they
want to invest so I often see people
trying to retrofit specifications of
some form to you know code that was
built by patching and so what are your
comments on that but this is a very
common thing that where that where the
specs have economic proven you gonna
bail yes well I could say it's better
late than never
you know I were in a period where you
know just rabbit expansion and the
wonderful or sad fact of life depending
on your point of view is that you know
anyone who can write a C program that
the compiler will accept can get a job
as a programmer and you have a user
commute large user community who is very
naive and you know will accept crap
because they don't know any better and
because you know that's the well they've
seen so I think it's going to take a
number of years before the whole field
matures to the point where quality
becomes important
you know it's eventually going to happen
you know it's happened at Amazon because
you know they're not doing it for
because they are you know so enthralled
by you know specifications or
mathematics or something they've got a
problem where they want people they're
building cloud systems and they want
people to trust their business to the
cloud and the only way they they cannot
maintain that trust if their systems
would lose or corrupt data and that
sorts of bugs that they find are ones
that could cause and corrupt you know
that could corrupt data and they're also
in a situation where oh well if we tried
testing it and if our testing doesn't
find any problem well it's good enough
they're in system that's so large and so
heavily used that anything that can go
wrong you know it's not if it will go
wrong it's when because if there's a bug
there it will eventually be manifested
so
you know people at Amazon are in a
business that's a lot more demanding
than your local garage startup and as we
get to depend more and more on computers
that will become more and more common
okay
you